maybe we can shoot our own reality show
how well do you know this famous
fictional quad
we'll take a behind-the-scenes look at
nikki ricky dickie and dawn
and talk about the real reason the show
was canceled and which star does the
best
chicken impression there was a lot of
laughter behind the scenes
but there may also have been a little
bit of drama
as well how fun is that what's better
than an episode of nikki ricky dicky and
dawn
an episode involving maddie and
mackenzie ziegler of course
these two have appeared on the show a
couple times including in the episode
keeping up with the kwadashians
according to maddie working with the
cast is great
i'm so excited i had so much fun the
first time and you guys are so welcoming
to me
but her favorite thing to do on set is
flip those tables
that's it maddie let the anger out just
turns out really crazy
the problem with basing a show around a
set of quadruplets is that if one
disappears
there goes a core component of the
series maybe that's why disney chose
dove cameron to play liv
and maddie nickelodeon learned this
lesson the hard way when actor mace
cornell
announced that he was leaving the cast
yes
finally he described his departure as a
mutual agreement that would allow him to
pursue other roles
since he didn't even wait until the
fourth season was over many fans
wondered if there was some drama going
on behind the scenes
mace did say that he would never want to
be a quad in real life and that handling
things on set
wasn't always easy no not at all
because it's hard enough being a fake
quad
on set fans know that the quads don't
always get along
and that might be a major understatement
mace admitted that his pretend siblings
often bugged him during filming but that
doesn't mean nicki ricky dicky and dawn
was a miserable experience
there was one co-star he loved spending
time with and that he and aidan
gallagher bonded
over their shared love of guitar
apparently the two of them would sneak
in jam sessions during their down time
on set
i do play guitar with nikki or aiden on
the show
speaking of off-screen interests did you
know that lizzie green is a gymnast in
real life
she's incredibly passionate about the
sport and had a chance to show off her
skills in the episode
ballet and the beats yes she really is
holding up her own leg in this scene
and had to do so for many many takes
impressive thanks no biggie in fact
lizzy wish she had more of a chance to
show off her skills and would have loved
to see an episode in which the quads
went to gymnastics camp
but if that wasn't an option she would
have settled for a gymnast guest star
like her personal hero
gabby douglas i'm so excited to be on
nickelodeon i'm a huge fan and it's just
an amazing opportunity
based on what you know about the nicky
ricky dicky and don cast
do you want to take a guess whose
nickname on set was troll
if you guessed mace you're right and
don't worry he doesn't consider it an
insult
this star claims he was called troll
because it was like a thing like the
internet source troll and i can actually
do the face
[Music]
matching up with a popular meme we're
not sure how this came up but it was
revealed that one of the quads does an
absolutely
excellent chicken impression
not only can lizzy do gymnastics but she
can also imitate a barnyard animal with
surprising accuracy
and i can make pretty unbelievable
chicken noises
you probably had no idea there was such
a talented cast behind nikki ricky dicky
and dawn
in the episode a briefcase of popularity
ricky gets in good with the cool kids
and has the honor of ascending the steps
but of course his siblings immediately
start trying to bring him back down to
earth
by informing his new headphone-wearing
friends that he sleep rhymes
they're not sleep rhymes they're sleep
wraps
but is immediately called out why don't
you wrap for us
right now when he does perform it's less
than impressive to say the least
yo yo my name is armin and i'm here to
say
brush your teeth not once but twice a
day
but just because ricky can't rap doesn't
mean we can say the same about casey
simpson
not only can he rap in real life but he
actually has tons of musical talents
i'm definitely taking singing lessons i
play piano i play guitar
i rap until mesa's sudden season 4
departure the quads mostly stuck
together
but sometimes the show needed a shake-up
from a guest star and on one occasion it
brought two former co-stars back
together
in the episode the mighty quad squad
actor phil lewis made an appearance as
the mayor
a guy you don't want to disappoint oh i
don't get disappointed
i get revenge he had actually worked
with brian stepanek before when the two
of them appeared on the suite life of
zach and cody
on the disney channel on-set reunions
can be a ton of fun
but don't forget that injuries are a
real risk behind the scenes
and if there's one star who knows all
about that it's definitely lizzy green
looking through some of the best
backstage bloopers we couldn't help but
notice that lizzy seems to take a tumble
a lot and we're not talking about what
she does on the gymnastics mat
ouch we wonder if this is a sore subject
for this star
in fact sometimes the cast can't help
but break character when they feel a
sneeze coming on
if you've ever wondered what it looks
like when these stars sneeze just take a
look
even the canine cast member who played
squishy paws couldn't help but let one
fly during filming
was there a lot of pollen on set or
something my beard caught most of it
speaking of dogs here's a canine related
easter egg you might have missed
in the episode the secret the quad
enters their house while talking amongst
each other
amidst the chatter you can hear them say
the words phoenix colonel
have you ever heard a hug seems like a
strange thing to say
but it's really a nod to actor mace
cornell or more accurately
his adorable dog phoenix everyone has a
part of nicki ricky dicky and dawn and
for lizzy green it's the time she got to
play dorothy in the wizard of quads
apparently the wizard of oz was one of
her favorite films when she was growing
up
and she admitted to looking for a yellow
brick road in real life when she was a
kid
well then i guess i'm going to see the
wizard she described working on this
storyline as a dream come true but
admitted it was also
a lot of work they had to rehearse the i
am dorothy song
and dance about 50 times just to get
every last step right
this is definitely by far my most
favorite episode of
all time have you gotten the sense that
lizzie green is talented behind the
scenes too
she may take a fall every now and then
but it turns out she really can sing
and that's her voice in the wizard of
quads but there was just
one little problem with recording her
voice lizzie was sick with a terrible
cold while filming this episode
she was constantly downing tea between
takes and her lyrics had to be added in
during post-production
after she recorded them with clear
sinuses and a non-scratchy throat
aidan casey mason lizzie weren't the
only kids who showed up to audition for
nicki ricky dickie and don
michael campion once auditioned for the
role of ricky but didn't end up making
the cut
later he was cast as jackson on fuller
house so it all worked out for him
another success story is thomas cook who
was also a contender for the role of
ricky but ultimately ended up playing
hudson on game shakers
having to get parental permission can be
frustrating as the kids learned in
quad pendants day in this episode dawn
wanted to get her ears pierced while her
brothers wanted to bring home a pet
snake
and their parents weren't a fan of
either plan but while don may have
wanted earrings
lizzie actually loves snakes i'm a total
tomboy and
love to hold spiders and snakes did you
notice something familiar about brian
stepanek who plays the role of tom
if you thought you recognized his voice
you may be right since he voices another
character on nickelodeon
brian can be heard voicing lynn loud
senior on the loud house
here you go mr grouse seven trays of
lasagna as promised
and you might have trouble recognizing
aiden gallagher in his more recent work
as he plays the super powered number
five on netflix's
the umbrella academy working on a show
can be difficult
and actress alison munn had an
additional challenge during the first
season of nicki ricky dickie and dawn
if you thought ann harper looked a
little different that's because she was
pregnant with her second daughter when
the show started
do you miss nikki ricky dicky and dawn
let us know what you think would have
happened if the series kept going past
season four
after sharing your ideas with us and
your fellow fans in the comments section
click subscribe for more from us here at
the things thanks for watching
[Music]
you